matelas sofa autres meubles et débris en
tous genres les vestiges de la journée
des déménagements étaient nombreux dans
les quartiers québec je trouve ce
réellement puisqu'une exposition
dégueulasse non mais je m'y attendais le
déménagement mais c'est sûr que c'est un
petit peu plus long qu'à l'habitude
peut-être si sur les trottoirs et les
reste encore du travail à accomplir dans
les organismes d aide aux locataires le
boulot est encore plus colossales en ce
samedi mais on répond aux situations de
crise pour souvenir encore une qu'il est
juste de surgir le ce matin une dame le
kit qui se retrouvait sans logement en
ce moment même à l'office municipal
d'habitation de québec on soutient que
55 ménages se retrouvent toujours sans
logis l'organisme avait reçu 554
demandes c'est plus du double par
rapport à l'an dernier c'est clair que
de plus en plus de gens qui ont de la
difficulté à trouver des logements
abordables sur le marché locatif de
québec c'est une évidence et la
situation est critique partout dans la
province alors qu'au moins 600 ménages
n'ont toujours pas trouvé de logement
c'était drôme une ville qu'ils sont le
plus nombreux en contrepartie ils sont
118 à montréal voulait dire ce chiffre
là c'est la pointe de l'iceberg
c'est un pâle reflet de la réalité dans
les derniers jours on a vu plusieurs
ménages locataires finalement choisir
des options qui n'étaient pas vraiment
des parents qui habitent dans des
logements beaucoup trop petits pour leur
famille cette réalité est également
observée par d'autres organismes qui
rappelle par ailleurs que trouver un
logement ne règle pas tous les problèmes
l'on commence à voir des appels et de
demandes de leucate a compris des
logements mais dont les logements sont
pas conformes le donc les travaux sont
pas terminées le ménage a pas été fait
donc souvent ils vont arriver dans des
logements en mauvais état le frapru
compte interpeller les partis politiques
lors de la prochaine campagne électorale
pour qu'ils s'engagent à financer 50
mille logements sociaux sur cinq ans ici
luis mon lapointe et radio canada à
québec